[Music]
on this thursday night relief and a
reprieve from russia's war in ukraine
hundreds of ukrainians make it to safety
in zaparisia while some russians hide
after criticizing the kremlin we have
very big troubles right now with the
freedom plus new blasts at that bombed
out steel plant quebec scraps most of
its mass mandates how politics could be
at play
while the u.s marks a brutal benchmark
in the pandemic and a long difficult
journey i hope nobody else of color has
to go through this an indigenous man
wrongfully arrested at a vancouver bank
on the importance of forgiveness
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin again tonight in ukraine heavy
fighting is still going on in marieuple
russian troops are trying to destroy the
last pocket of resistance at that huge
steel plant that would give russian
president vladimir putin his first
significant success before victory day
on may 9th in russia when that country
marks the surrender of nazi germany in
the end of world war ii it's hard to
know exactly what's happening at the
steel plant russia controls access it's
believed hundreds of soldiers and
civilians are trapped beneath it where
they've been sheltering for weeks as
well more than eight billion dollars has
been raised at an international donors
conference in warsaw to help ukraine
though the country's president vladimir
zelinsky is begging the world for more
and there are diplomatic disagreements
about how u.s intelligence is being used
to target russian generals on the
battlefield redmond shannon has our top
story tonight
another evacuation convoy from mariupol
rolls its way into zaparisia the red
cross says more than 300 people escaped
the besieged city but it's thought 100
000 are still left behind
new footage from ukraine's as of
battalion shows large explosions on the
site of the azov style steel works where
soldiers and an estimated 200 civilians
are sheltering underground
the battalion's deputy commander again
blaming russia for the standoff saying
enemy forces are at the site russian
troops have encircled the complex for
weeks but the kremlin insists they have
not pushed any further than its
boundaries
just as other borders undergo symbolic
change at mariupol's city limits workers
replace ukrainian language road signs
with russian ones
elsewhere in the donbass region more
destruction in the past day local
authorities saying five civilians were
killed and 25 injured in bombings
russia going a step further claiming it
killed 600 ukrainian troops overnight
but russia is taking heavy losses too
ukraine claims it has killed up to 12
russian generals a new york times story
says u.s intelligence has helped make
that happen ukraine
needs over 12 000 tons of humanitarian
aid every day in warsaw poland's prime
minister co-chaired an international
donor conference to support ukraine
raising more than eight billion dollars
and now president vladimir zelinsky says
he also needs you here in one click you
can donate funds to protect our
defenders to save our civilians and to
rebuild ukraine ukraine launching a
website for individual donors to
contribute military humanitarian and
reconstruction aid
well he might some estimates say it will
cost half a trillion u.s dollars to
rebuild ukraine after the war
when that will be no one knows redmond
shannon global news london
prime minister says the russian
president has apologized to him after
russia's foreign minister said nazi
leader adolf hitler had jewish origins
after a phone call with putin israeli
prime minister naftali bennett said he
accepted putin's rare apology and said
he thanked him sergey lavrov was asked
on italian tv why russia claims it's
de-nazifying ukraine when president
vladimir zelinski is himself jewish
lavrov said that hitler also had jewish
blood
one of russia's richest men claims he
has gone into hiding hired bodyguards
and lost billions of dollars all because
he posted a message on social media
criticizing the war in ukraine oleg
tinkoff is one of the only members of
russia's elite to openly condemn the
russian invasion but as jeff semple
reports he certainly isn't the only one
being targeted
anti-war protests in russia over the
past two months typically haven't lasted
long
fifteen thousand people have been
arrested under a new law passed in early
march criminalizing public opposition to
the war in ukraine russians aren't even
allowed to call it a war instead it's a
special military operation
it's just insane situation right now
this russian high school teacher says
within days of the invasion school staff
received a crash course on a new
curriculum told to teach their students
the kremlin's preferred version of
events
about the fake news in ukraine about the
so-called nazis in the
uh uh
east side of your ukrainian
territory in response cameron manafly
posted this message on instagram
expressing concerns and saying i do not
want to be a mirror of state propaganda
when he refused his principal's request
to remove the post he says he was fired
and dragged out of the school by
security
after that he fled the country
getting worse day by day
we have
very big troubles right now with the
freedom and that crackdown on freedoms
extends all the way up to the elite
russian business tycoon oleg tinkov told
the new york times the kremlin forced
him to sell his stake in one of russia's
biggest banks which he founded after
this instagram post in which he
condemned putin's crazy war adding that
innocent people and soldiers are dying i
really
applaud him this former russian deputy
finance minister now in exile says many
russian business people are afraid to
speak out but fiercely oppose the war
it's a
destruction of the economy economy is
demolishing and they say that okay we
we're going down and we don't know
where's the end where's the bottom this
canadian was recently added to a
fast-growing list of foreign journalists
and politicians banned from visiting
russia for criticizing the kremlin
things are not going as planned for
vladimir putin in ukraine so that
domestic repression that repression of
any sort of criticism has only
intensified over the past two months and
i suspect that it will only get worse
the worse the war goes for russia he
says the more desperate and dangerous
its president will become
jeff semple global news toronto
the world health organization has a new
estimate of how many people have died
from covid19 the who believes nearly 15
million people have died in the last two
years from causes related to the virus
that's almost three times as many deaths
as officially have been reported per
capita one of the hardest hit countries
is the united states where it's now
believed nearly one million americans
have died of covet 19. as jackson
prescott reports that stunning toll has
not eased the deep divisions over
vaccines and precautions in the u.s
american tragedy is etched into the
monuments of washington d.c
the 58 000 soldiers killed in vietnam
the 418 thousand who never returned from
the second world war yet the greatest
loss of american life in a generation
has gone largely unacknowledged the one
million who've died from kovid 19. the
person who would comfort you
when you suffer a humongous loss like
this
is the person who's gone kovid took what
mattered most to ariane bennett scott
her husband of 30 years
they were partners in life and in their
restaurant business scott's empty spot
is in bed next to me every night and
every morning
it's in my heart next to me it's in my
business
every day when we would make choices
despite being cautious and fully
vaccinated scott contracted covet in
december
he died after nearly a month in hospital
you don't want to be my husband in a
hospital room saying to me on facetime i
wish i'd worn my mask
i promise when i get out i'm going to
wear my mask all the time
in the u.s huge numbers of people remain
unmoved by those risks they have scoffed
at precautions and refused vaccines at
some of the highest rates in the world
the anti-vaccine groups are so
emboldened right now vaccine scientist
dr peter hotez has run out of words to
describe this uniquely american failure
200 000
unvaccinated americans since may 1 last
year have lost their lives because they
refused to get vaccinated because they
were defiant of getting vaccinated i
don't even know what you call that
anymore when it comes to understanding
how it all happened dr rick bright knows
better than most we never anticipated
political and fear interference in an
outbreak as a former government
scientist he blew the whistle on the
early pandemic response of the trump
administration as too political and
under-prepared imagine when you have the
best vaccines and the best drugs and the
best diagnostics on the planet that you
would have political leadership
that would discourage their use that
would politicize science today dr bright
believes many americans have simply come
to accept mass death as a way of life
people are really tired and people are
confused people are still getting mixed
messages about the importance of some of
those life-saving measures
for all those vocally opposed to
vaccination
and those who are simply over it there
is an unmistakable silence
a void filled with those who cannot move
on because of what they've lost and
that's the brutality of the disease i
think
it's terrifyingly lonely
for both the people who are trying to
help you and the people going through it
every day hundreds of new families enter
that same lonely world
two years and one million deaths later
americans have not found the collective
will to stop it from happening
jackson prosko global news washington
a canadian province hit hard in the
early stages of the pandemic and tends
to lift its mass mandate next week
quebec will be the last province in this
country to do so its top doctor says the
peak of the sixth wave has now passed
and covet 19 numbers are down though as
dan specter reports many suspect the
reason could also be political
the shoppers inside this montreal
grocery store will soon look very
different masks will no longer be
mandatory in public indoor spaces in
quebec it will be the last province to
drop the mandate
it's fun to know that
finally we're going to turn the page
like other jurisdictions quebec will
still require masks in certain settings
like public transit and hospitals prince
edward island removes its mandate friday
it's the only other province still
masking ontario and alberta lifted
requirements in march still many in
montreal feel it's just too soon i'm
still going to keep it for for quite
quite a while
if the convince is a risk
i are going to keep it quebec says with
cases hospitalizations and deaths
trending downward the timing is backed
up by data but like in ontario quebec
voters head to the polls soon
immunologist dr andre veyet thinks that
is a major motivator he would have
waited longer you know they do surveys
and they see how the mood of the
population is going and i'm sure this
kind of thing is not the only factor but
it's one of the factors montreal public
health has released new research about
outbreaks in workplaces finding during
the first three pandemic waves that
people who work in food processing
warehousing and manufacturing were the
hardest hit though hard lessons have
been learned and vaccination is more
widespread than ever workers in those
sectors remain vulnerable it's not
because the masks are not mandatory that
it's mandatory not to wear them and the
more we don't wear masks many
immunocompromised people are feeling
anxious and left behind
it's like they're taking away from
drivers your airbag and your seatbelt
and so if i'm still wearing a mask it's
not enough people are of course free to
continue wearing masks with officials
reminding quebecers to respect the
choices of their neighbors dan specter
global news montreal
more rain is coming to southern manitoba
this weekend but forecasters say it's
unlikely to be enough to worsen the
flood
these aerial views from the area near
steinbach show much of the region
underwater up to 10 more millimeters of
rain is on the way local states of
emergency have been declared in 25
communities and the red river valley is
being closely monitored as this spring
flooding season continues water levels
aren't expected to return to normal
until the end of the month
squaring off coming up the first debate
between federal conservative leadership
hopefuls
[Music]
five of the six candidates vying for the
federal conservative leadership are
facing off tonight for an unofficial
leadership debate it's the first time
they're on the same stage presenting
their visions for the future of the
party abigail beeman is tracking it
tonight
how much did you get from
answer the question this is a company
that was welcomed
lots of attacks not much detail on
policy that's not true i was among the
loudest voices that you were not one of
the loudest voices mr paulie leslie
lewis targeted perceived front runner
pierre pauliev in fact i did it if i
could it's popular if i could if i could
i in fact probably have refrained from
firing back perhaps because he doesn't
want to alienate lewis's social
conservative supporters should there be
a second ballot and he aimed his fire at
the other leading candidate former
quebec premier jean charae your liberal
party took a half million dollars of
illegal donations when you were the head
of that party the average trucker has
more integrity in his pinky finger than
you had in your entire scandal plague
liberal cabinet
and cheray who has been out of the
spotlight for some time fired right back
mr poliev during that period supported
an illegal blockade you cannot make laws
and break
and then
say i will make laws for other people
ontario mpp roman babber largely focused
on covid no one on the stage stood up
for canadians until the truckers came to
town he was kicked out of his provincial
conservative caucus for criticizing the
ford government we do not need lockdowns
it was the greatest catastrophe
perpetuated on our generation while mp
scott hsn consistently aimed for the
high road and here we are calling each
other names
what canadian is going to trust this lot
we've got to do better brampton mayor
patrick brown is not taking part his
campaign says he's too busy selling
memberships
and overall selling membership seems to
be going well sources tell global news
the party is on track to hit half a
million members that would be nearly
double the count at the last leadership
race in 2020.
abigail you watched the debate do you
think it helped make clear the
differences in their policies
well donna over 90 minutes there wasn't
a whole lot on policy it was clear most
candidates feel opposing any coveted
mandates and lockdowns are popular with
voters since even though there are few
federal restrictions in place candidates
went back to that issue criticizing
restrictions there was also a lot of
media bashing but what emerged most
clearly was a better picture of the
dynamics and who feels threatened by
whom cheray and pauliev spent a lot of
time attacking each other and lewis
attacked pauliev although he did not
fire back the first of two official
debates takes place next week in
edmonton with all six candidates on
stage donna all right abigail beamon
thank you
first the ball then the batter ahead
more fortune for the luckiest yankees
fan
[Music]
rescuers in china have pulled a woman
alive from the debris of a six-story
building six days after it collapsed
the woman who was conscious was rushed
to the hospital said to be in relatively
good condition she was trapped for about
132 hours search crews had used sniffer
dogs and drones to find her
26 people were killed when the rear of
the building suddenly caved in on friday
at least nine people have been arrested
including the building's owner four
faced charges over liability suspected
of ignoring building codes
a young baseball fan had another
incredible moment last night to cap off
an unforgettable week nine-year-old
derek rodriguez met his baseball idol
new york yankee superstar aaron judge he
got the chance because of this this
beautiful moment when a blue jays fan
caught one of judge's home run balls and
handed it right over to the boy
rodriguez says he not only got to meet
his hero he also made a new best friend
next a bank settles with an indigenous
man and his granddaughter wrongly
accused and arrested in vancouver
an indigenous man and his granddaughter
who were arrested and handcuffed by
vancouver police after a bank accused
them of fraud have now reached a
settlement of their human rights
complaint against the bank of montreal
maxwell johnson an artist from the
heltzik nation was simply trying to add
his granddaughter's account to his own
bank employees not only refused they
called 9-1-1
now after two and a half years johnson
is reflecting on what he calls a long
hard journey
part of our culture is to forgive we
don't hold on to anything
maxwell johnson never wanted to be the
center of this story yet today he came
back to the same spot on a vancouver
street in front of a [ __ ] bank which
wrongly accused him and his
granddaughter of fraud his human rights
complaint against the bank finally
settled i'm just glad to be able to
stand up for myself and for my my kids
and grandkids and
other people that are afraid to come
forward to
stand their ground it was here two and a
half years ago that he and his then 12
year old granddaughter were arrested and
handcuffed all he tried to do was open a
bank account using their indigenous
status cards as id
the bank refused suspected fraud and
called the police
there was no evidence of fraud no
charges were laid and the bank has since
apologized
in april an independent review found the
two officers acted without reasonable
and probable grounds they were suspended
for several days it took
a lot of trust away from my
granddaughter my son and myself it's
been really hard
i suffer from a mental illness called
panic disorder
and i had to overcome the fear of uh
talking in public again
johnson lives here in the great bear
rainforest on bc's central coast a
member of the heltzik first nation he's
an artist and a cultural leader in his
community his work adorns the front of
the big house
his financial settlement with [ __ ] hasn't
been disclosed but for johnson this is
about so much more than money our people
have been on the coast for over 14 000
years
that's longer than the pyramids have
been up
so i just want people to educate
themselves more about first nations
issues and our culture
in the spirit of forgiveness he's
created this piece of art and gifted it
to the bank on the bottom it's got the
[ __ ] logo on there just
so is that we're working together to
get past this and
be on good terms it's good medicine
the officers who made the arrests have
been invited to an apology ceremony in
bella bella
they have yet to accept
johnson did one more thing today he
closed his bank account with [ __ ] if you
went through something i did you'd want
to change banks too
it is the end of a chapter he says but
not of the healing
late today [ __ ] put out a statement
saying it's pleased a settlement has
been reached and that it's an important
step in reconciliation
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen today was red
dress day in canada to remember the
countless indigenous women and girls
lost to racism and violence
we leave you tonight with some of the
gatherings across the country according
to the national inquiries final report
in 2019 indigenous women and girls were
12 times more likely to be murdered or
go missing in canada than any other
demographic
thanks for watching jeff sample will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see
you on saturday for the new reality
bye